if you're a younger guy you're trying to  move up in the workplace I want to tell  you the secret that took me way too long  to understand effort is the universal  currency of respect it doesn't matter  how lame you might be or how lame you  might think you are how not good you are  at something every single person across  cultures across age groups respects  effort and so the one thing that we can  control is the effort that we dedicate  to a task and so if you can put  everything you have into achieving what  you want people will give you the  respect you deserve based on what you  are doing not the outcome because the  outcome my friends will come